when you talk say about domestic
violence and there's a sort of thesis
behind it and i'm putting it in a bit of
a nutshell here so feel free to to
rephrase it that
men uh in the end if men are pushed too
far by a too aggressive of feminism
there will be a backlash and that there
is you know there's a sort of
undercurrent of of violence be it verbal
well that's a warning not a not a that's
a warning no but but it's not a journey
that kind of suggests that there may be
sort of fault in those who push
progressivism too far they will get a
backlash some people of course see that
as a bit of a permissive environment for
bad behavior
well
people tend to confuse describing the
likelihood of something with supporting
the fact that it exists and i'm
describing the likelihood of something
not not supporting the fact that it
exists if you push too far on the left
you're going to get a backlash on the
right that's how things work
and this is just a derivation of that as
far as i'm concerned